Good morning, John.
Your new book, The Fault in Our Stars, has
- aside from being totally gripping and touching
and hilarious and genius, which no one knows
yet, because I've read it, but they haven't
- has become something of a sensation. Like,
I don't know if you know this, but I don't
think that anyone has ever done what you just
did. And of course, when I say you, I mean
us.
Uh, including me, because I helped. Uh, I
made half of our 875 videos. And more than
me, the people who, uh, watch the videos have
helped. THANK YOU! But yeah, number one on
the Amazon and Barnes&Nobles bestseller charts,
four days running with, like, no publicity
at all!
And, uh, this story was just written up in
the freakin' Wall Street Journal, and John,
the people who read the Wall Street Journal
are like very important. These are peeople
who can seriously impact, like, your future
career. And those people are probably coming
right now from the Wall Street Journal article
to check out the vlogbrothers and see what
this is all about. And so, as your brother,
I'm going to make sure we put our best foot
forward for those people, so that you have
maximum opportunity to get uh... no, I'm not.
[Instrumental version of Shake-A-Booty plays]
Are the Wall Street Journal viewers gone yet?
And that was a very punishing punishment.
Also, because Geoff Pepos, the guy who came
around with me to film all of this, 'cause
I was pretty sure Katherine wouldn't want
to do it. I told him it was a punishment,
and he was like "Well, Hank, now that you
have told me it is a punishment, I'm going
to make sure that it is punishing." Like the
one in front of the restaurant with me humping
the drunk people sign? That was a very long
shot.
The song that you heard during that is a karoke
track from a song from Ellen Hardcastle called
"Shake-A-Booty". And that was produced by
the magnificent Luke Conard, who you probably,
you probably knew that, just by listening
to it. But it's my first dance song! And I'm
really excited to let you have the full version...
eventually.
Speaking of which, pre-orders for Ellen Hardcastle
begin never! John's book has a very long pre-order
time, and my album has no pre-order. We've
decided! So, that's different for me.
John, I really do want to congragulate you
on the, the pre-success of The Fault in Our
Stars. It deserves it. It's gonna be a pretty
big deal, I think. And thank you so much to
the nerdfighters for, uh, making this a huge,
huge freaking deal! And being a part of something
that I think is pretty historical in the,
uh, in the timeline of the publishing industry.
Uh, this is going to be amazing. All the success,
even the Wall Street Journal article, is very
well-deserved. John, I'll see you on Monday.
Nerdfighter: Hey, what's up?
Hank: Nice to meet you. Is it okay if I hump
your car?
Nerdfighter: Yeah, go for it.
Hank: Awesome, thank you.
Random guy: Kiss that fish! Yeah!